one word to describe what's left to see
this season on Braxton Family Values
oh I have to do it my way down I can't
do one world anyway I have to do a long
series of Oh Traci Braxton it kind of
teasing us with what's still to come
this season on Braxton Family Values you
made a decision they made a decision one
of my sisters the show saw her entire
family go on strike leaving adjust Traci
to film with pals like Phaedra Parks
this came together for a kind of dark
time for you and your family yes it did
yes do you know if your sisters have
been watching the shows that they are
not a part of I think secretly they
watch so they haven't shared any
thoughts with you of like this is what
they think of no because tough they
called you a traitor how hurtful was
that for you that that hurt me you know
because it's like why am ia traitor
because I have my own mind you know the
thing is um we had a contract and you
know and when you have a contract you
helps to fulfill that contract did you
feel a responsibility to kind of carry
the show on your own or not of
responsibility is was being mature and
fulfilling my promises me Trina and
Traci said that we were going on strike
she didn't even tell us that she showed
up from the scenes from next week looks
like the sisters kind of creep back into
the show
Oh slowly yeah how did that come about
that they started to get back in front
of the cameras and sharing their lives
again I guess they wanted they want to
do that to tell their side Maddie
you know what that business decision and
you guys consider the show to be
business or this business because you
have to it's a business there are
contracts money and all that it is it's
a business check is involved so could
this be the end of the show as we kind
of knew it or are we gonna get back to
seeing all of you sharing your lives
full force like we were used to know you
may have TV because you know buddy my
contracts nice little pillow so we got
we gotta wait and watch
yes I hear you talking about problems
with production and the network you I
don't understand why that impacts your
relationship with each other we do know
the whole family does reunite with the
iyanla Vanzant yeah for a mediation oh
okay how does that go is she able to fix
your life checking her pulse you know
what my post telling me this she fixed
my life I say she didn't fix my life but
she helped me see better and keep my
process process going positivity did
everyone walk away with that oh you got
a watch on Braxton Family Values I mean
can talk about me I got a good plan
would on Thursday then down to class we
were talking about Tamar she tweeted but
ya'know was the devil and then deleted
so do you have any responses to that and
you know in my opinion for myself I
don't think I'd go by myself I think she
helped me with a lot of other things but
I don't know she didn't fix my life
because right who I'm still with my
family and that will never be fixed we
love the show though
it's reality it is just always gonna be
crazy who of your sisters are you
talking to today
let me see Tony called me earlier to
want to call me earlier Shana called me
most of the time ok Tony she mostly call
me to himself even when the walk out doc
until you said some hurtful words was
given to me but you know we have to talk
what's the best piece of advice she gave
you in this time keep family first
however your business separate
[Music]